so on my wish list this year is the
nikon s 1000 PJ now this is a 12.1
megapixel point-and-shoot camera it also
shoots video at 30 frames per second
with sound and it's got this nice large
LCD on the back and it sounds pretty
standard Danny that's because it is
standard except for it has what are the
dimension it has a projector built into
it no way that's pretty awesome yeah
that is awesome it's a 10 lumen
projector and it can project any image
or videos that you've taken from this
camera onto a wall that's cool so if
you're at dinner and you want to show
off some pictures rather than passing
around the camera to everybody take a
look at the you know the LCD you just
pop it onto a wall dim the lights and
that's exactly wallah yeah it's a really
easy convenient way to share you don't
have to use a projector or plug it into
a computer or anything like that your
grandma can do it how much does sharing
costs I believe it's four hundred and
thirty dollars that is correct so you're
gonna pay a pretty penny shares so
Steven what's it what's what the hell
they do ah what's with the helmet cam
check this out so this is the contour HD
okay it's a ruggedized camera that
shoots in 30 frames per second or 60
frames per second 720p or up to 1080p
which is true high def that's really
cool but why would you actually stick it
on top of the helmet why would you just
carry it with you well if you're
snowboarding or skiing or just walking
down the street or walking down the
street while eating a burrito and
drinking a soda yes this gives you
complete hands-free video it is made out
of anodized aluminum oh it's pretty
rugged and tough it has a very simple on
and off so you just slide it up and down
on off it also has a 135 degree view so
when you're snowboarding or doing any
kind of athletics it gets really really
wide angle frames but what's really cool
about it is it has a micro SD card so
it's up to 16 gigabytes of video footage
from my head how much video footage with
it
16 gigabyte why no but how many hours I
believe up to three hours that's great
pretty fantastic so I got a footage of
stuff no one's gonna walk if you're on
the mountain you know you're out on the
town you can get tons of little footage
you pop it on top it off right before
you're on the lift really simple pretty
neat so Stephen how much is rig costs
three hundred and thirty dollars uh does
that include the help the helmet is not
included